- [Voiceover] The landscape
artist who designed
New York City's Central
Park believed that providing
scenic settings accessible
to all would not only
benefit the public's
physical and mental health
and also foster a sense of democracy.
So immediately this one sounds weird,
and the reason why it sounds weird is that
we start saying, "not
only," and when you hear
a not only or when you read a not only,
you expect to see a but also.
So you would normally
expect to see someone say,
"Hey, I not only," say, "ate a sandwich,
"but I also," or "but also.."
Not only did he eat a
sandwich but also he ate a...
Or he drank a cola, or he had some fries.
Or, but he also.
So you would expect a but also as part
of that construction, and we see over here
they do an and also.
So I don't like it as it is,
so I'm gonna rule out the first choice.
That's always the one as it is.
So do they have a but also here?
And they do.
But also foster a sense of democracy.
So really the right one...
Because whenever you see a not only
you also want to see a but also.
So the landscape artist who designed
New York City's Central
Park believed that providing
scenic settings accessible
to all would not only
benefit the public's
physical and mental health
but also foster a sense of democracy.
Yeah, that sounds exactly right.
The not only says, "Hey,
not only did you do
"this one thing, but you did other things.
"But you also did this other stuff."
So this one is definitely the best answer.